[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 el
aborto legal el libre y seguro es una de
las prioridades de la agenda feminista
en américa latina'
sólo cinco países de la región aún lo
prohíben completamente y aunque en
general es los pedidos desde las calles
y desde los legislativos van en
dirección de la legalidad también hay
retrocesos ese es el caso de honduras
que vamos a conversar hoy la nación
centroamericana ya ratificó el decreto
de ley que reforma el artículo 67 de la
constitución orientado a prohibir
completamente del aborto la decisión
también afecta al matrimonio entre
personas del mismo sexo pese al rechazo
de organizaciones dentro y fuera del
territorio
justamente más de 80 organismos
hondureños e internacionales expresaron
su rechazo absoluto a la aprobación del
decreto de ley que prohíbe de manera
absoluta del aborto en honduras una
iniciativa que denunciaron como violenta
compara los derechos humanos de las
mujeres
el aborto en cualquiera de sus causales
es un delito en honduras pero el pasado
21 de enero se endureció aún más la ley
por medio de la reforma de un artículo
constitucional para que la prohibición
establecida desde 1982 sólo pueda ser
eliminada con los votos de tres cuartas
partes de los 128 diputados del
legislativo
respecto de una violación
el decreto de ley fue aprobado por el
parlamento y aplica como un blindaje
para el artículo 67 de la constitución
que ahora se leerá al que está por nacer
se le considerará nacido para todo lo
que le favorezca dentro de los límites
establecidos por la ley se considera
prohibida e ilegal la práctica de
cualquier forma de interrupción de la
vida desde su concepción
la movida conservadora del feto el mismo
estatus legal que una persona y fue
aprobada junto con la modificación de
otro artículo que teclea las uniones
igualitarias al establecer que el
matrimonio civil en la nación
centroamericana sólo puede ser entre un
hombre y una mujer
las decisiones provocaron la condena de
unas 80 organizaciones de derechos
humanos y cientos de mujeres marcharon
en las cercanías del congreso en
tegucigalpa el 27 de enero elevando su
voz de rechazo nuestro motivo por estar
acá es visibilizar los burros que son en
el congreso nacional para nosotras como
mujeres
exigimos se respeten nuestros derechos
humanos nuestros derechos
sobre la salud sexual reproductiva de
las mujeres en su declaración dijeron
que en 2017 se registraron 101 partos de
adolescentes por cada 1000 embarazadas
en todas las edades en 2016 unas 770 y
cinco niñas tuvieron que ser madres
producto de una violación mientras que
anualmente se registran 2300 casos de
violencia sexual
vamos a analizar el tema y por eso nos
acompaña desde tegucigalpa honduras a
jessica sánchez activista y directora
ejecutiva del grupo sociedad civil
jessica bienvenida a ella soy yo
muchas gracias
vamos a comenzar hablando de los países
latinos sólo cinco de ellos el salvador
nicaragua república dominicana haití y
honduras prohíben el aborto en cualquier
causal para las organizaciones de
derechos humanos o como la suya ahora
precisamente su país no solo no avanzó
en el tema sino que retrocedió porque
bueno esto hay que verlo desde la
perspectiva de el avance como como decía
la noticia de la movida de la derecha
desde el año 2009 como dice rita segato
las mujeres en más formas de la guerra
somos el objeto de la guerra entonces
empezó con la prohibición de la pista de
anticoncepción de emergencia pae para
cualquier caso no entonces nosotras
sentimos que el mensaje fue que vayan a
ser sus casas porque la mayoría de las
mujeres que estábamos en las calles
protestando en el golpe la mayoría de la
población éramos mujeres y mujer
embarazada no puede estar en la calle
entonces le jesús responde esta movida
ahorita y creemos que esta es una
respuesta a la marea verde a la
aprobación del aborto en
en argentina y claro honduras dando el
primer golpe estado del siglo 21 no se
podía quedar atrás con la respuesta al
blindaje al aborto quiero decir también
que esto es una oleada de retroceso de
derechos humanos en agua de las mujeres
tuvimos que pelear muchísimo para
cambiar uno para sostener los derechos
que ya teníamos en el actual código
penal que entró en vigencia este mayo
del presente del año pasado perdón en el
informe de vídeo veíamos que las
organizaciones feministas se unieron en
un comunicado de rechazo y que citaron
101 partos adolescentes por cada 1.000
embarazadas en 2017 porque para ustedes
el aborto legal podría ser una solución
humana al problema y más allá de eso le
pregunto también esto evidencia un grave
problema de educación sexual y de
prevención del embarazo adolescente
vuelvo te cuento cuando el golpe también
se prohibió las guías de educación
sexual
el tema se toca poco en las escuelas
esos fueron las fuerzas fundamentalista
en las iglesias y mira el dato que
nosotros tenemos es que son 21 mil
partos anuales promedio de niñas entre
10 a 18 años cuando nosotras como un
movimiento feminista en una reunión del
g-16 preguntamos a personeros el g-16
donde está toda la cooperación
preguntamos a la secretaria de salud
porque sí porque serán estos estos
partos no entonces nos dijeron que ellos
estaban seguros que el 90% de estos
partos eran a causa de violencia sexual
y nosotros les dijimos no es el 100%
porque es una niña porque aquí la
constitución y le dice que y las leyes
dicen que es niño hasta los 21 alguna
niña no puede consentir en un hecho de
relación sexual pero también no puede
consentir en llevar a cabo llevar a
término un embarazo
e
en esas condiciones no siendo una niña
muchos también preguntamos qué pasaba
con estas niñas de 10 11 años que tenían
que parir y nos dijeron que de 10 a 15
años la mayoría en cesáreas porque su
cuerpo no lo podía resistir entonces
para nosotros es un derecho humano
porque primero está el derecho de la
niña de la mujer a decidir
y a salvar su vida muchas de estas niñas
mueren a causa de sus intervenciones no
tenemos todavía el dato de cuánto porque
el estado aquí se ha brindado se ha
blindado a la secretaria de salud en
relación a los datos entonces lo
consideramos un retroceso en materia de
derechos humanos porque viene acompañado
de otras por ejemplo
y se eliminó del código penal la
violencia intrafamiliar contrario a
todos los códigos y en todas las
convenciones firmadas por el estado de
honduras y se cambia por maltrato
familiar ocasional y habitual o sea
pueden ser siempre como dieron los
diputados o puede ser de vez en cuando
dice se echan decimos nosotros es
continuando la violencia hacia las
mujeres entonces en la prohibición del
aborto
en el marco de un
de una guerra en general contra las
mujeres que tiene por objetivo el
retroceso a nuestros derechos y dónde
están las fuerzas fundamentalistas no
sólo de este país sino creemos del
continente dando un ejemplo de cómo se
hace derecho y fundamentalismo desde
américa desde américa latina
hacia el mundo que no solamente es la
interrupción del embarazo sino todo lo
que rodea a estas políticas los
embarazos adolescentes de jessica
derivan en pobreza para los países
porque las mujeres que entran tan
jóvenes en la maternidad se quedan
limitadas en sus posibilidades y en las
posibilidades que tendrán sus hijos y
sus familias a futuro también es cierto
que el embarazo adolescente les cuesta
dinero a los sistemas de salud de los
países y esto ha sido un argumento
utilizado en el pasado para la
legalización sin embargo yo quisiera
preguntarle su opinión es más desde una
visión humana porque tampoco podemos
decir que el aborto tiene que ser por
ejemplo la solución para que el estado
se ahorre plata o para disminuir el
flujo de personas en los sistemas de
salud
es que el tema aquí es que se nos quita
el derecho a decidir
tenemos quita la capacidad de decidir y
hablando de honduras que ya que hay te
desaparece del mapa porque ya nadie
quiere hablar de honduras estamos
hablando del país más pobre de américa
latina' uno de los países más pobres del
mundo entonces estamos hablando de que
en materia de derechos vamos en
retroceso o sea pobreza en disminución
de derechos y en el centro estamos las
mujeres y esto ha ocasionado el por
ejemplo estas mujeres con tantos hijos o
como embarazos no deseados o con
violencia sexual
no quiere decir que el aborto es la
causa pero sí es una de las causas por
las cuales las mujeres migran de este
país tenemos estudios de que la
principal causa por la que las mujeres
migran son 21 en la violencia dentro de
la violencia y la amenaza o se desplazan
forzadamente que es lo que estamos
diciendo el amenaza de violencia de
femicidio para salvar la vida 2 es la
amenaza de violencia sexual y 3 es la
amenaza de reclutamiento por parte de
los miembros del crimen organizado de
sus hijos e hijas entonces hay veces que
hay un conjunto y cuarto perdón en la
extorsión o sea antes la señora ponía un
negocio de carne asada un negocio de
tortillas afuera ahora no se puede
entonces estamos cercados por varios
lados tanto por el crimen organizado
como por las fuerzas fundamentalistas de
este país si el estado quisiera
realmente actuar sobre eso mejoraría las
condiciones de seguridad de las mujeres
pero eso no está sucediendo entonces no
es el tema del aborto es el tema del
conjunto de los derechos de las mujeres
por ejemplo cuando no
que no puede no vamos a poder denunciar
violencia doméstica porque no es lo
mismo que te pego un sábado cada mes así
lo dijo el diputado mario pérez que es
el mismo que hizo la reforma que que te
peguen todos los sábados verdad es
totalmente diferente las penas son
diferentes y este por y quiero destacar
que el aborto ya estaba prohibido en
honduras o sea esto es un guiño como te
digo a las fuerzas fundamentalistas a
trump a los seguidores de trump también
para decir aquí estamos jefes estamos
haciendo bien la labor de reprimir y
violentar los derechos humanos y
específicamente los derechos humanos de
las mujeres
jessica pues muchísimas gracias d por su
enfoque y por darnos todo el contexto de
lo que sucede en honduras y al final en
américa latina volveremos próximamente
con más programas y más temas para
analizar en ellas hoy sigan en france 24
[Música]